l'apathie dont elle-même ne pose pas de
problème c'est à dire c'est
l'information qui est transmise est une
information qui n'est pas une
information sensible en elle-même et qui
est transmise aux médecins traitants qui
est légitime pour disposer de cette
information
donc c'est pas c'est pas ça le problème
le problème et éventuels et l'intention
c'est à dire pourquoi on fait ça et quel
résultat on veut obtenir
et qu'est ce qu'on fera avec cette que
fera le médecin avec cette information
qu'est ce qu'on lui demande de faire
avec cette information est en gros la
question et dépression qui seront mises
sur les sur les personnes plutôt que de
l'information
quand une fois ce qui cause vraiment le
problème à mon avis c'est l'intention
qui est derrière l'intention du
gouvernement qui est derrière qui bon
soyons clairs voudrait aller vers une
obligation vaccinale mais n'osent pas le
faire et donc cherche des moyens
détournés d'imposer la vaccination ou
aux gens tant les devoirs que j'ai vis à
vis de ses passions ses de leur apporter
des informations claires pour qu'ils
puissent faire un choix bien éclairé mon
consentement éclairé
je crois qu'il faut pas aller au delà la
mère de la promotion de la vaccination
on est simplement l'un pour
éventuellement aller voir des gens qui
sont dans le doute
moi je suis pour autant comptable de sa
santé donc est-ce que je dois
l'informer oui ce que je dois décider
pour lui non je suis là on a formé et de
lui apporter les éléments pour que je la
forme il faut que je sache
éventuellement ceux qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés je prête particulièrement
attention aux gens qui ont des troubles
de la motilité parce que ce sont des
gens souvent qu'ils n'osent pas
s'exprimer
et aujourd'hui on moi je prends mon
petit frigidaire portable et s'il le
souhaite on les vaccine ma mission n'est
pas de rattraper les débuts du
gouvernement et elles ont été nombreuses
bon après je sais pas si j'avais été au
gouvernement si j'aurais fait mieux mais
il ya eu des cas des messages qui était
très contre-productif de la part du
gouvernement qui ont quand même effrayé
certaines parties de la population a la
chance d'avoir une agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament qui publie des
chiffres chaque semaine notre médecin
d'être informés de la réalité des
chiffres est de ne pas regarder les
choses on inverse une information
qui était pas l objectif soyons clair
aujourd'hui l'information qui a été fait
sur la personne n'est pas objective et
c'est notre formation s'est pas
seulement le mac sens et toute la
pandémie c'est toute la gestion qui
étaient dix estiment catastrophique en
terme d'information et ou des fausses
informations à commencer par parent par
les masques étaient véhiculés par le
gouvernement mais aussi neiges de jus
dois le dire par le corps médical
et là ça pose plus de problème c'est
qu'à démontrer l'épidémie c'est qu'ils
avaient c'est que le corps médical
d'une façon générale diffuser beaucoup
plus des opinions que des informations
objectives et ça c'est improbable il ya
des choses qu'on ne sait pas en matière
de vaccins et c'est bien le problème si
on prend les vaccins arn messagers bon
moi je suis vacciné j'ai décidé de le
faire
pas spécialement à titre individuel mais
par esprit de responsabilité collective
parce que c'est ça le fond du problème
mais il reste des questions aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya pratiquement plus de
contacts de l'industrie avec les
praticiens
je dire de la profession de de nos
visiteurs médical elle est sinistré je
dire qu'aujourd'hui les visiteurs
médicaux
il ne vit une visite que les pharmacies
pour passer des contrats commerciaux
mais c'est une visite chez le médecin
c'est terminé personnellement la liste
moi la première chose qui va être fait
c'est que elle va intégrer on va la
réintégrer dans les dossiers des
patients dossiers qui sont sécurisées
sur l'hébergeur données de santé et
effectivement on conservait une fois
pelé est transféré sur les données de
patients on va pas on va pas garder la
dc la procédure qui est utilisé et est
effectivement de transmettre une liste
mais qu'ensuite cette liste elle est
intégrée dans chacun des dossiers
l'information est intégré dans le
dossier médical du patient par le par le
médecin et que la liste et est détruite
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de 2,2
pour moi de difficultés probablement que
la méthode n'est pas forcément la bonne
pour le pour le faire peut-être on
pourrait on pourrait faire mieux mais
c'est vrai qu'on des dents détendre on a
faim cette pandémie a montré une
désorganisation assez considérable de
l'administration delà de la santé donc
bon on peut pas espérer on ne peut pas
espérer grand-chose de 2,2 différents
voilà je pense que vraiment le point
c'est uniquement le fait que c'est une
liste
enfin c'est un fichier est un fichier
pose toujours un problème quelle que
soit l'information la transmission d'un
d'un fichier l'information elle-même
pour moi ne pose pas de problème